I'm gonna give you a little insight into
my psyche welcome to my mind I'm very
sensitive to my immediate environment
and for that reason I've developed an
obsession a passion for understanding
how I'm triggered in order to then
exercise creative choices to steward my
awareness to steward my experience
because ultimately we all want
fulfilment we all want happiness we all
want this illusive sensation of
well-being which is so hard to find and
the self-help section in the bookstore
is so crowded with tips and tricks to
find your bliss the truth is for me
there is a direct correlation a direct
relationship
[Music]
the landscapes that surround me in the
states of mind that they give rise to in
the words of the psychedelic philosopher
Terence Mckenna you become what you
behold
so I become would I behold
so what landscapes work best
what landscapes wake me up and inspire
me what landscapes
jool to me into the now
so first and foremost landscapes that
are novel new spaces that I haven't been
to before
which likely induce a sense of first
sight unencumbered by knowingness
because the pen there's in scene that's
of the adult mind the jaded miss that
comes from a place you've already been
to blinds you to it
we know this it's called hedonic
adaptation perhaps you can meditate
again and again and again for years to
get to the point where you see familiar
places with new eyes but that's really
hard a lot easier is to just constantly
go to new places become an explorer that
works
to new places and also paths that
beckoned and paths that lead to places
that I can't quite see so that they
evoke the mystery of what's around the
bend when I turn right over there what
will I find
[Music]
I can somewhat see that where I'm going
doesn't look dangerous but there's
enough mystery still to keep me engaged
and so the combination of the new place
and then particular styles of landscapes
with particular qualities already
embedded into them they run a particular
script in my mind I become like a child
and engrossed in the moment I'm immersed
in the now and of course as Michael
Pollan says there is another word for
this extremist noticing that that sort
of rises within you this extremist
noticing this virginal noticing of the
sense8 world and that word of course is
wondered which is a precursor to all and
ah is described as an experience of such
perceptual expansion which you can say
is literalized in front of me right now
a place of such perceptual vastness and
experience
of mind and place of such perceptual
vastness and expansion at the mental
models of the world that you've
assimilated in your brain the familiar
algorithms of adulthood the old scripts
are obliterated to make way for the new
landscape and for the new experience
so you're hurled back into a childlike
reverie what Diane Ackerman calls deep
flag there's a giddiness in it
immediately your senses are heightened
arrested your attention is focused
you're in the zone you're in the flow
you're in the forever box as Michael
Pollan writes in his book how to change
your mind
deploying psychedelics can help to
certain kinds of drugs maybe cannabis
travel and novelty certain kinds of art
all these things walk the signaling in
the brain forwards and backwards so
memory which can blind you from the
present and foreboding which can make
you worry rather than enjoy what's
happening are blocked when the signal
soars is that was a block here hurled
into a present that is literally
wonderful
wonderful wonder being exactly the
byproduct and the unencumbered sense of
first sight that virginal noticing to
which the adult brain has closed itself
thank you michael paalan so what happens
then when you take all those boxes and
you become a child man you have to
marshal a response you feel euphoria
from the amount of engagement the normal
distractibility the normal leap frogging
to the conclusions dispensing with the
here and now are put aside and all I
want to do is be here now and talk about
it and this is the inspiration for my
work and this is the inspiration for my
life this is my noble aim this is my
orientation this is what keeps me going
this is what saves me from myself
[Music]
and this is what I want to share with
you enjoy